I really like pvp and destiny so when
you know the sort of event iron banner
comes up level advantages enabled I was
interested right you want to hop in I
like level 27 hunter I wanted to see how
my gear was gonna stack up if like my
weapons were gonna feel different like I
just bought this legendary hand cannon
from the future war cult want to check
it out so I'm gonna match and it like
honestly feels a lot just like the
crucible you know my weapons feel kind
of the same my my ebb and flow my like
performance was kind of within like
normal bounds of how I do depending on
the day and the match I'm in the folks I
was fighting against from mostly like
high 20s so even that profile didn't
seem different so on the flip side of
that me and Chris decided okay let's see
how big the disparity is so we made
level two characters that we had brought
into the crucible and all we got was the
first white reward that you get from the
gunsmith it's like a normal assault
rifle or pulse rifle whichever one you
choose right we're like okay we're
fighting level 26 27 plus you know
guardians and we're like we're probably
get smashed right because they have
probably over a thousand armor and they
have you know exotic rifles and
legendary weapons and we have this very
subpar like shitty assault rifle that
you know does 26 damage where's their
guns probably doing like 250 plus right
on paper at least so I started a warlock
I go in at level 2 i'm literally using
the first assault rifle you find in the
game I have no double jump I have no
grenade I have no super and running
around in these iron banner matches ah
there's a difference I didn't do as well
I wasn't as high on the team sort of
ranking at the end of the match as I
usually am but I feel like the
difference wasn't so much that someone
was one shotting me with a sniper when
they otherwise weren't or someone was
you know their auto rifle was chewing me
up faster than it otherwise would width
I was playing my level 27 hunter I also
felt like I was doing I like I did
pretty well
we've won some matches as low characters
iron banner is supposed to make it so
that all your gear matters and you're
supposed to feel really powerful
compared to someone else so like all the
time you spent playing the game to get
an advantage over other people is
supposed to be more apparent I will say
though that all the people that are
doing most of the people that are doing
iron banner are are the more hardcore
kind of pvp people so I actually do
notice the skill level kind of raising
and that aspect of it is fun because
you're actually competing with some of
the best probably out there uh so I
don't know I feel like iron banner the
salient takeaway is like this just where
the Sharks play like you want to play
against some of Destiny's best PDP
players they're playing an iron banner
because they want to get that rep it's
something new and also like that's you
know the iron banner bounties are
tougher it's like be the top player
score wise in the match get tilt kill 10
players without dying these is kind of
analogous to the Queen's wrath right
those were harder bounties for PVE these
are harder bounties for PvP and so
naturally PvP skill players are going
after them the kind of sad parts about
it is that you don't get rewarded if you
lose the game you don't get any iron
banner rep so then there you know if the
team's getting stomped you know by like
five thousand points or something they
all just start leaving because they know
that they're not going to get a reward
so they're better off leaving the
leaving that game and queuing into
another game and that's unfortunately a
little bit of like poor game design in
my opinion they should get punished for
leaving there's things like dota where
you know if you leave a game too many
times or something like that you're
suspended for 15 to 30 minutes without
being able to play like a real match and
there needs to be stuff like that in
place I don't know how they're going to
do it or if they're gonna do it but it's
not cool for people to just go oh I'm
not going to win this game I need to
leave this game so that I can actually
get rewarded like that's not how the
system should work but all in all I
think iron banner is pretty fun it's a
very competitive it's especially more
fun with you know when you play with you
know some of your friends your coat
workers and you guys start getting into
it you know communicating and then
trying to just you know win so that you
get iron banner reputation but again
hopefully they have those small fixes
and hopefully bubble to stop actually
being able to compete with level 29
because that's weird